now let's fly over to the strip for a
ride that gives you a bird's eye view
and takes your vegas adventures to new
heights
we are here at the newest attraction the
newest ride on the strip and i hear
we're flying over the real wild west
you bet the real wide west 22 scenes 11
different uh locations across the world
wildlife so cool okay before we fly over
what do we gotta do to get ready first
things first we go to buccal land for
safety before fun yes understood awesome
and how does this work this is the very
first flight ride in las vegas you guys
took over a movie theater how does this
process work okay so we're sitting in a
ride vehicle and there are 40 seats on
each ride and there are four ride
vehicles so we're gonna this gate in
front of us is gonna pop down oh my gosh
getting real scary but very cool you bet
we're gonna roll all the way forward
with our feet dangling and then we're
gonna move in motion with the movie so
win sense mist
music all to make you feel like you're
flying that's incredible and the real
wild west is not the only movie that we
get to immerse ourselves in here right
correct we're actually showing two
different locations so our first anchor
experience is the real world west over
the western part of the united states
and then we're also featuring a flying
experience from iceland grand opening i
hear you already have so many people
excited already have bought tickets well
1200 plus tickets sold in advance of our
opening so really really pumped because
it just means that people are excited
that we're here and they're gonna get to
enjoy you know three and a half years of
hogwarts oh my well congratulations to
you lisa and today
we are so excited to fly over the real
wild west let's do it awesome all right
[Music]
whoa isn't that cool that looks like so
much fun no i know and it's and we were
laughing about the fact that it was the
what was it devin the regal showcase
eight movie theater oh my gosh he's our
he's our movie theater
yeah so it's really cool inside you guys
got to go grand opening today
i